I saw that when I was an intern at the
Bronx District Attorney's Office this is
when I knew I want to become a defense
attorney I was listening to endless
hours of phone calls between this
low-level heroin dealer in the Bronx and
an fna someone from the NYPD and he was
working obviously as a snitch whereas an
undercover and the guy he every week you
would say look I want to get out of this
you know he was a he was a Hispanic guy
from the Bronx he dealt a little bit of
heroin and but every time he said look
this is the last time you know I want to
get out of this I want to you know do
something legitimate with my life I
don't want to be exposed anymore I don't
want to do this anymore and every week
the undercover would say look I got
another you know hundred buyers I got a
bird about to make a lot of money let's
do it for another week and he pushed
them and he pushed him for years and he
built up a huge case and then they
arrested him on these major trafficker
charges and this guy I heard the phone
calls he didn't want to be involved in
this he didn't so there is a lot of
corruption on the on the prosecution
side it's not bull it'd be unfair to
call it corruption um you know at the
end of the day did those undercover
agents put a gun to this guy's head and
say you're gonna deal everybody want me
Joyce but they lead you down the road
into a certain choice they lead you down
you know much at all huh cuz I'm it hits
the newspaper it's just the headline
drug dealer arrested you don't really
find out find out how he becomes a drug
dealer this is my entrapment exists huh
yeah but the entrapment defense look the
entrapment defense at the end of the day
is very very very tough because you need
to show that you had no disposition
whatsoever but for that contact made to
you by the you know the undercover and
usually these people are predisposed to
look the heroin dealer in the Bronx he
was drug dealing but what caught me and
what didn't sit right with me was every
week when he said look I ever I really
am done don't come to me with any more
buyers and then every week the guy would
say look I know you said you're done but
I just found a million dollars that we
can you know we can flip a million
quickly to these city of these buyers
you know in downtown
and you do [ __ ]